Fox News Alert its decision day for
president Trump in just four hours from
now he'll announce the Supreme Court
nominee it's a bold move that could
reshape the High Court and country for a
generation and cement his presidential
legacy the sources telling Fox News the
president Trump has made a final
decision after reports that he was
considering four candidates judges Brett
Kavanaugh Amy Kony Barrett Raymond
Catholic and Thomas Hardiman Senator
Lindsey Graham saying the president
can't go wrong with either of these
contenders Republicans are holding four
lottery tickets and all of them are
winners if your conservative Republican
to four people named particularly Thomas
Heidemann I'm glad he's on the list or
all winners and every Republican should
embrace these picks
meanwhile regardless of who the
president picks the stage is being set
in the Senate for a major confirmation
battle Democrats are using scare tactics
to try and damage Trump's nominee we
already know that president Trump's
nominee will be prepared to overturn the
precedents of roe v wade and NFIB vs.
Sebelius we know that because President
Trump has said so it's about more than
the next election it's about what in
country the United States of America is
going to chart as its course in the
future I've never seen a president
United States in effect make himself a
puppet of outside groups and choose from
a group of right-wing fringe ideologues
I frankly don't even think we should be
considering this nominee all right we'll
begin with Gutfeld
I mean you've seen a few of these
confirmation battles that was this one
any different shaping up in your opinion
I'm actually lucky cuz the decision will
be made at nine o 1:30 Eastern Standard
Time just as Hannity goes on the air
pretty happy about by the way thank you
all for having me great I'm not as funny
yeah I am not as funny as Greg Gutfeld
I'm warning everybody at home I have
dollar at at 9:03 Eastern the left is
going to be in the process of trying to
smear besmirched slander destroy the
character of whoever the president picks
you know we use the term balking now
almost as a verb or you think of what a
great Justice I the Clarence Thomas if
you haven't read his book which is
called my grandfather's son it is one of
the great American hero success stories
want a shake in his head it is that one
of the best books I've ever read and
he's become one of our great justices
whoever the president picks and I think
those are the names the great thing is
is that he told us all of this ahead of
time and it will be another promise made
promise kept and the other thing newt
gingrich and i were just talking and i
and he said to me he goes before the
president makes his decision tonight
close your eyes and for 30 seconds just
think imagine if it was hillary making
that choice it would be no one nobody
close to who the president will pick
president believes this is about
judicial philosophy constitutionalism
originalism versus judicial activism and
it really that that's pretty much and do
you think dana the democrats could
overreach to a certain point where it
really hurts to them in the midterm
elections by going so crazy against a
pretty you know reasonable nominee i
possibly and you know dick durbin i
think we just had him there saying that
it's it's more important to stand on
principle to them than it is to worry
about those red state Democrats I don't
know if that will actually hold true for
example take somebody like Heidi
Heitkamp in North Dakota just today the
Fox News Power Rankings moved her seat
from a toss-up to likely Republican and
that means that she's got a big decision
to make and it because that race is
moving away from her she has a way than
to buck her party the Democrats and vote
with the president and try to keep her
Senate race competitive if she decides
to do that so I think you'll see that I
think McCaskill will be under pressure
in Missouri I think Donnelly will be
under tremendous pressure in Indiana I
don't think that the pressure on Collins
and Murkowski on the Republican side
will be that persuasive at the end of
the day when he when they voted for
Gorsuch they were there they might have
had concerns I think that at the end of
the day they will also be for whoever
the president picks here I could be
wrong of course but I think my gut
instinct is that there's gonna be a lot
of fire and fury so to speak but
when the vote is called that the
Republicans will come home and from the
list Kimberly it doesn't seem of the
four people that we've been talking
about there's any really red flags among
either one of them that no one no one's
screaming David Souter really loud or
anything like that it looks like a
pretty sure thing no matter who he goes
with yeah I think it's really it's like
you can't even go wrong with the main
like primary ice cream picks right
vanilla strawberry talking me prefer one
a little bit over the other also they're
all fantastic solid choices they've been
incredibly well vetted by Federalist
Society by the Heritage Foundation as
well and the initial list of 20 that the
president put together with his team and
with advisors was outstanding he then
also listened to input and feedback from
other people added five additional names
and then subsequent to that he's
narrowed it down to four quality
candidates for people that would
admirably serve this country and welcome
the opportunity and have pledged to
follow the law and have demonstrated
that when you look at the review of
their judicial record of their opinion
some have written more opinions than
others that will always give the other
side some meat to be able to pick with
to try to take issue with whoever the
president chooses but he made an
outstanding choice was Neil Gorsuch and
I fully expect that he's going to make
another very good choice an announcement
tonight during the nine pm era in the
Hannity show and we'll find that out and
in fact 32 of the top deans Scholars and
attorneys government officials have
concurred that the president's choice
will be confirmed and put through so
regardless of what side you're on
democrat or republican they agree with
that liberal or conservative so
ultimately and I agree with Dana and
that they will in fact get this through
so we just have to you know trust in the
judgment he's made solid choices and
like Sean said these are promises made
promises kept he promised to put
conservatives constitutionalist that
would follow the law on the bench and I
fully expect that that's who he'll
choose tonight the one are you having
nightmares over these potential sets
look they're gonna get a fair hearing
Hannity is worried that he's not funny
enough I think this is hilarious what
you guys like an echo chamber in here oh
he's picked wonderful people
how was they been thoroughly vetted by
who heritage and the Federalist Society
you kidding me this is what
woman thought was talking about fringe
candidates that's it by the Senate
before because we're talking about the
Supreme Court and remember Dana we're
talking about a president who has said
you guys say promises kept he said he
wants somebody's gonna undo roe v wade
take away abortion rights in this
country that's not someone who would do
away with gay rights which is not true
and these guys are sitting you say
perfectly normal
Blumenthal is right these are fringe
candidates well then why do the
Democrats confirm them all on previous
occasions the key thing here Kimberly is
are you going to abide by the laws of
the United States and recognize
precedent that's correct what you have
especially in the case and I think this
is your number one pick Amy call me
Barrett right she said precedent doesn't
matter to her so I mean that's good
that's why you had a call from the
Senate majority leader saying hey I
think that's a little trouble if you
pick her but what my point about Roe is
or not
what happens if Roe was overturned what
happened do you really believe there are
a number of states who would overturn
abortion with New York New Jersey
California Illinois probably but I can
count 45 states that would at least if
not 48 or 40s your assurance to the
American people well I 2/3 it's 2/3 are
better say we don't want roll it there's
over there is nuanced and
intellectualism these are people that
have an immerse themselves in
constitutional thoughts and writings and
their particular cases that they work on
but let me concede a point you know what
I really do think dick Durbin is right I
think that every every Democratic
Senator in a red state needs to go and
commit political suicide
hi-dee-hi can't Claire McCaskill they
need to put it all on the line and
oppose whatever the president picks I
think that's great advice and I think
Dana's reported it so senators Donnelly
mansion and hide camp all Democratic
senators in red states that are running
for reelection were invited to the
announcement tonight but they declined
correct and I think that what you're
going to see is to the contrary
tremendous pressure on susan collins and
lisa murkowski to Republicans who are
pro-choice Republicans
to say hey you know what this is too
much you can't just have the Supreme
Court become a rubber stamp for a
right-wing agenda legitimate this is not
where's the evidence you say these
things in your scaring trying to scare
Nina Totenberg literally made the
comment that it's the end of the world
as we know it and dick durbin is telling
these red state senators Democrats to
commit political suicide no it's not
political oh yeah it will be it's a
matter of conscience and voting for what
is right as opposed to Hillary laws yes
so Hillary won the popular vote to
unpopular president and an unpopular
Senate trying to force on the highest
numbers he's ever hung her up right wing
agenda but the one why is it then in
good conscience in good faith and having
studied all of this in terms of the US
Court of Appeals and these judges where
they've been appointed why did the
Democrats vote to confirm them to begin
with if they were not qualified on the
United States Supreme Court if they
weren't qualified already to serve on
the court of appeals and they were put
through by Democrats liberals
conservatives all of the like they were
confirmed they were put forward as of
total I though those names have been
proffered by the president no they're
not yes it I think they're proffered
because he believes that they will do
what he promised as you said earlier
promises made promises get overturn
abortion rights in this we're gonna go
to break but when we go to break just
close your eyes as Shaun recommended and
just imagine if Hillary Clinton was
president boy wouldn't that be a
wonderful